de toutes ces squeeze on se retrouve
aujourd'hui pour un clip du jour donc on
est le 22 novembre
alors ça se passe sur ps3 et bien
évidemment sur modern warfare 3 c'est
parti alors on n'est donc qu'en
domination sur la mappe fallen avec un
bon accent français
alors c'est adrien 51 tandis qu'ils
jouent à la mp5 silencieux et ben tu es
un premier avec celle ci que tu es le
deuxième un petit troisième avec les p5
1 petit 4e mais là il sourit sur scène
faisait neuf etc à monsters qui j'en fus
5 et 100 refait deux pour la flandre à
pau pour bien finir le déjeuner bravo à
lui en tout cas si tout est situé à un
petit chanceux ou tout simplement un
expert 2 call of duty je t'invite à le
peloton clips sur youtube et à l'envoyer
à l'adresse email suivante c ou d x qg à
ambages gmail.com si marquez à l'écran
belin c'est pas faux d'ailleurs pourquoi
tu lady autistes la nature à calmer we
put es qui toi
il faudra aussi tuer ajoute une petite
description histoire de savoir ce que
ton clip contient et il faudra aussi que
tu y ajoutons psn gamer tag ou alors le
nom que tu as sur pc quand tu joues en
ligne en attendant les gens je vous
souhaite de très bonne partie est de
bien geek et sur call of duty
à bientôt by bo dérobé au goal of may a
tué fail
quand tu apprendras plagie khaimah